هنا في الرئيس الاوكراني اي علاقه ببلاده
بمقتل مالك مجموعه
مضيفا ان الجميع يفهموا من له علاقه بمقتل
جاء هذا في معرض اجابته على السؤال يتعلق
بالدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا بالطائرات خلال
مؤتمر صحفي
عندما تحدثت اوكرانيا وناشدت دول العالم
بشان الطائرات لم نقصد هذا الذي حصل قصدنا
شيئا مختلفا تماما واردنا الدعم على الرغم
من ان هذا ربما يساعد بالتاكيد بطريقه ما
اولا ليس لنا علاقه بهذا الامر بالتاكيد
اعتقد ان الجميع يدركون من له علاقه بما
جرى
كما قال الرئيس الاوكراني
اخطر شيء بعد مقتل بروغوجي هو وجوده
20,000 من مقاتل فاغنر خارج السيطره وقد
يشكلون خطرا على اوكرانيا اوبلاروسيا او
بولندا او حتى على روسيا حسب تعبيرها
كم من الموت تسبب لنا به نظام بوتين وايضا
بريجينو مرتزقه لذلك لا استطيع قول اي شيء
ايجابي اعتقد ان الموضوع الاخطر هو وجود
عشرين الفا من مقاتل فاغنر خارج السيطره
واعتقد ان هذا ما تبقى منهم يجب ان نفهم
لمن يشكل هؤلاء الخطر الاكبر لاوكرانيا او
لبيلاروسيا اولادا ومن الممكن لروسيا ايضا
في غضون ذلك قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
انه لا يوجد دليل قاطع على وجود بريجوجن
على متن الطائره التي تحطمت لكن من
المحتمل جدا انه مات واضافه وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه ان رحيل سيكون له تاثير عميق
ومزعزع للاستقرار على مجموعه واشارت الى
يتميز بصفات من الصعب ان يضاهيها الخليفه
له على راس فاجنر حسب التعبيره
معنى
دريدي ومن تدفير شمال موسكو حيث تحطمت
طائره مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
نبدا معك رانيا اذا انت من امام مقر
مجموعه
كيف يبدو تبدو الاجواء في محيط هذا المكان
خاصه مع التجمع
مؤيدين
يعني لو تنقل لنا صوره من هناك
نعم غنوه يعني يمكن القول يعني يعني شريحه
يعني من المواطنين الروس لا تزال تتوافد
الى هذا المكان بين فتره واخرى حتى في
ساعات المساء يعني امس ومنتصف الليل شهدنا
قبول من قبل سكان
لهذا المكان لوضع اكليل الزهور احياء
لذكرى
زعيم شركه فاقنا الذي حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يتم التاكيد رسميا على الاقل من ثبت
اللجنه التحقيقات على وفاته
غنوه كما تبدو الصوره خلفي هناك يعني
حاليا يعني هناك عدد من المواطنين الروس
الذين قادموا الى هذا المكان اود الاشاره
الى ان هذا المكان هو يعني مركز شركه
فاغنر العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه هناك بعض
الاعلام المنصوبه في يعني امام هذا المبنى
هناك شموع يتم وضعها اكليل الزهور لابد من
الاشاره
والى ان يعني
نحن نعلم انه يعني كان على تواصل مستمر
عبر مختلف وسائل الاعلام
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مع المواطنين
الروس كان يدلي بتصريحات يعني مؤيده
لروسيا ولعظمه روسيا ليس فقط في الداخل
وايضا في الخارج وعليه فان هناك شريحه
يمكن القول انها ليست بالصغيره من مؤيدين
بريجوجن وايضا مقاتلي فاجنر الذين بحسب
هؤلاء الذين على الاقل يتواجدون هنا
يقومون يعني تحقيق اهداف ليس فقط الشركه
على وجه التحديد بل اهداف روسيا وقيادتها
يعني اود الاشاره غنوه الى ان يعني حتى
الرئيس الروسي امس وخلال كلمه يعني وجهها
لذوي ضحايا هذا هذه العمليه او هذا الحادث
حادث تحطم الطائره في
كان قد اشاد
تحدث عن انه نعم بالفعل اقترف اخطاء كثيره
ولكنه ايضا حقق نجاحات وكان موهوبا بحسب
تصريحات الرئيس الروسي
بوتين نفسه وعليه فان هذه الشخصيه الغامضه
الصعبه ان صح التعبير يعني تجد من يدعمها
على الاقل في الداخل الروسي
بعد اعلان الرسمي من جانب بوتين انه قتل
بيجهوشن
ودعينا الاشاره لان الرئيس روسيا خلال
الكلمه التي وجهها لذوي ضحايا هذه هذا
الحادث كان قد كان حذرا في تصريحاته من اي
ناحيه وهو انه قال فانه في حال تاكد مقتل
بريجوجل واشاره لانه وفقا للمعطيات
الاوليه فان هذه الطائره كانت تقل مقاتلين
شركه فاغنر فانه يقدم التعازي على ما يبدو
حتى رئيس روسيا فلاديمير بوتين لم يحسم
الامر مئه بالمئه غنوه على الرغم من انه
بالفعل هذه التصريحات هي اشاره واضحه الى
مقتل وجميع افراد الطاقم طاقم هذه الطائره
ولكن ترك الامر بوتين على ما يبدو للجنه
التحقيقات نحن نعلم حتى هذه اللحظه اللحظه
التحقيقات لا تزال قائمه بل واكثر من ذلك
حتى التصريحات الرسميه الصادره من قبل هذه
اللجنه تتحدث عن انه يعني جثث الضحايا
مشوهه كثيرا وانه يصعب التعرف عليها يعني
بص انه لا يزال هناك يعني تحقيقات
والترب الطب الجنائي والجيني فحص الحمض
النووي حتى هذه اللحظه لا تزال مستمره على
الرغم من ان هناك نعم سريعا عثمان حديث عن
ان بعض قاده باجنر قد تعرفوا على يعني
زعيم قواته عبر وشم على سبيل المثال على
جسد اوت كينوا يعني وبنصر
لليد اليسرى ولكن امس ليله امس شركه فاغنر
اشارت على انه لا يجب الاستماع لاي
تصريحات تصدر حتى هذه اللحظه كون قاده
فاجنر حتى هذه اللحظه رسميا لم يقوموا
بالتعليق ابدا على هذا الحادث وعلى وفيما
يتعلق ب يعني بالضحايا والجثث وما الى ذلك
نعم امين موجود
انت موجود في تذفير حيث سقطت هذه الطائره
وعلى ضوء ما قالته رانيا للتو رغم حديث
بوتين الا ان هذه الحادثه ما زال يكتنفها
الكثير جدا من الغموض
ينقص هذه القصه اذا صح التعبير وهو
التاكيد الاخير والنهائي المتروك
للجنه التحقيق الروسيه التي ما زالت تعمل
سواء في هذه المنطقه التي تحطمت فيها
الطائره او في مختبرات الطب الشرعي سواء
في مدينه او حتى في موسكو كما يعتقد حيث
نقلت جثث واشلاء الضحايا العشره الذين
كانوا على متن هذه الطائره وايضا تقوم
بتنشيط تلك المنطقه التي ترونها خلفي
والتي هي مطوقه الان ولا يسمح لاحد
بالوصول اليها طبعا وهناك غموض ايضا يكتنف
مساله العثور من عدمه على الصندوقين
الاسوددين وايضا المهله التي قد تحتاجها
لجنه التحقيق الفيدراليه الروسيه من اجل
على الاقل توضيح ما جرى واعطاء تصريح
لربما لتوضيح المسار تسير عليه هذه
التحقيقات الى الفصل الذي وصلت اليه على
سبيل المثال هذه التحقيقات هناك تكتم في
الحقيقه كبير من قبل الجهات التي تشرف على
هذه التحقيقات سواء من وزاره الداخليه
هيئه الامن الفيدرالي الافيسبي الروسيه او
حتى لجنه التحقيق التي لم تدلي باي تصريح
رسمي لوسائل الاعلام او حتى للراي العام
في روسيا منذ انطلاق او منذ وقوع هذه
الحادثه ربما هناك سؤالين اساسيين الان
السؤال الاول يتعلق بمصير الصندوقين
الاسوددين اللذان بطبيعه الحال اذا ما تم
فحص محتواهم سيتم الاجابه على الكثير من
الاسئله خاصه
حول ما جرى خلال الدقائق الاخيره قبل تحطم
هادئه طائره والثانيه المتعلقه بوضع لنقل
الختم على مساله مقتل
بالتاكيد رسمي بعد التعرف على الجثه او
بعد فحص الحمض النووي في المختبرات من قبل
الخبراء طبعا هذه المساله قد تاخذ لنقل
ايام باعتبار ان
تم نقل الجثث يوم امس من هنا من هذا
المكان فجرا تقريبا وحطام طائره مازال
موجود هناك في تلك المنطقه
هناك حديث عن ان الحطام تناثر في منطقه
واسعه يبلغ قطرها نحو كيلومترين ونصف
والاعمال لم تتوقف منذ يوم امس في البحث
عن بعض المتعلقات التي ربما قد تساعد
المحققين في نسج خيوط هذه التحقيقات
الجاريه او
الايجاد لرب بعض القطع التي ما زالت يعني
ضائعه في تلك الغابات المنطقه واعره في
الحقيقه لم نحي تضاريس ولا من ناحيه وجود
غابات كثيفه في تلك المنطقه ولكن كما سبق
وقلت هناك تعتيم هناك تكتم وهناك ايضا حذر
في التعامل مع هذه المساله ليس فقط من قبل
الجهات القائمه على التحقيقات بل حتى على
مستوى وسائل الاعلام الروسيه لا تذكر هذه
القضيه بشكل واسع ولا يعني حتى هذا المكان
الذين الذي نقف الان لربما نحن وسيله
الاعلام الاجنبيه الوحيده اضافه الى وكاله
او وكالتين لا يتم تغطيه وتسليط الضوء على
هذه القضيه وربما في ذلك
اولا اتاحه
للوقت امام المحققين من اجل اكمال عمليات
التحقيق ثم انتظار بان يتم الحسم في اسباب
تحطم هذه الطائره من
مصادر الرسميه ولعل ما ستتوصل اليه لجنه
التحقيق وماسه تصرح به خلال الفتره
المقبله بعد اكمال
عملياتها
وتحرياتها في هذه المنطقه ستكون كفيله
بطبيعه الحال عثمان على الاجابه على كثير
من الاسئله التي ما زالت معلقه وخاصه تلك
المتعلقه باسباب هذه الحادثه خاصه مع وجود
شهادات وحقائق لربما يعني تؤكد او تضع على
الاقل فرضيات عديده كانت سببا في تحطم هذه
الطائره باي شديد وشكرا لك شمال موسكو
مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
وكذلك الشكر موصول لمراسلتنا فيرج رانيا